10 degrees left. Do you think he's in one piece.
Clay you're back already dude. That's great. You fuckin asshole . Wohhhhh
That's a weird way to thank me for saving [your] life buddy, but you're welcome  oh shooting me was an act of kindness
dino-buddies, you know
What's wrong with you [gotta] stop [Shootin] Alex? That was my bad?
California Highway Patrol, that's [where] [I] [fell] [from] that armored car job. [I]
Think some of their own were involved I want you to go on the inside going to cover within the [department] of awesome
You're going to be with a rookie named John baker. You're Gonna be Francis, LLewellyn Poncherello
Fucked-up name are the first two female names
John none of these scores, maybe even the lowest standards
You've had 23 surgeries, I feel pretty darn good
I'm on a pharmaceutical regiment that helps a lot behind that you can write a motorcycle
I'll give you that yes, ma'am. Like a motherfucker. [I] like you. Thank you. Good night guys. Thank you
What's up? I'm John Hunter Ellis awesome, man. We're partners pretty badass dude it up for battle looking like Ups driver
Yeah, that's super cool. This job is crucial for saving my marriage
[what] are you wearing my uniform, so I thought you probably wanna see what I look like in all brown great, John
It's like you're three beers, too intimate almost Elf motorcycle. Cop I got no emotion
This your job fine to 5:30 cops
Michael never [can't] go
Yeah, great job
I think [on] things on the [bone]. [I] got it. Are you guys talking [shit]?
I mean think you said they like to bike see [with] pointing at my dick. I feel like and I heard poppy
[no], I think it's small said it's real so boston. You make the bike look tiny oh
Have to take a look. I hope that you're not preying on girls with low Self-esteem
Like by the hair like how straight their teeth are yeah, we're gonna be shallow real talk. She ate [my] lunch
She ate your ass everyone's eating everyone's ass. What about hygiene if you go to the bathroom when you shoot baby wipes?
Queen like
24 hours solve this case for you five. There's no way to track this guy. Why don't you can of space?
We don't have a fucking bat computer right Google
He's been carrying me [over] that bath. I'll drag you there, but I'm not gonna cradle you like a new [wife] saved your life
I knew you were gonna bring that up. Just get it over with
The new Faceplant into my pubic mom's no no no no that could have swore I felt
you know your nose or your lips might be like a
little bit of contact
When you get intimate with you gals is oral expected like
Paint has with the bus. Oh yeah, that's [and] [above] at standard while things have changed
you